oui je regarde les statistiques c'est
plutôt une exacte ce que vient de dire
puisque beaucoup d'enfants naissent en
fait
au canada on les produits divers illness
tôt l'automne ah oui c'est vrai on va
expliquer aux enfants pourquoi ça
fonctionne les choses fonctionnent ici
mais c'est une question à poser aux
professeurs la prochaine fois maintenant
alors autour de la table alice chantal
tandem est avec nous bonjour alice
stefan sahm urban qu'on voudrait avoir
toutes les semaines qu'il le désire
ardemment mais les petits plaisirs faut
faire attention à abuser les internautes
que nos invités
vous avez pas l'air sûre on a deux
invités à accueillir aujourd'hui
alors là avant de savoir qui c'est qui
sait exactement de quoi ils vont parler
vous connaissez la tradition c'est la
vidéo 5 images et c'est facile
aujourd'hui à lisser les hors concours
parce qu'elle elle a eu 20 de quelque
chose n'est pas comme elle fait les gens
dans les yeux je suis seul en
compétition c'est ça oui tout seul avec
les internautes bien sûr dont il ya un
million de personnes plus fin vous
regardez les images chaque match et vous
dites c'est quoi le sujet aujourd'hui
ils auraient besoin d'être peut-être les
images sont des invités ça vaut mille
mots
oui pas médicale à mourir non non parce
qu'on voit pas le visage
attendez c'est la selva potager le
problème pulmonaire non r oui monsieur
tout à fait vous tombez paix parce que
ça m'a interpellé cette semaine passée
de nouvelles pathologies qu'ils
n'étaient pas connus avant et rend plus
cdc de les adolescents et géronte est
l'image de les adolescents qui fument et
là avec
l'appareil de vin portage pas commencé
qu intéressant en tout cas on va pas
seulement parler de là c'est une forme
de maladie pulmonaire
oui son apparition 5
ça fait la une des journaux cette
semaine il ya bien sûr les cas noté
depuis septembre aux états unis car oui
on en avait avant d'aller vers les
spécialistes pour faire le point sur la
situation et voir qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire maintenant pour essayer de
minimiser les dégâts les gâchis parce
que c'est sa présence est des villes
entières qui sont sacrifiés sous le
pressait d'être je sais pas moins que je
comprends pas ce que c'est le papotage
tout à fait mais j'ai déjà fumé donc
durant l'entier des canadiens et des
adolescents qui ont une attirance
particulière pour ses cigares naître là
c'est des jeunes qui sont attirés par
l'emballage par les saveurs diffuse sur
tous les serveurs seront donc en plus il
n'a pas encore cette stigmatisation
comme allah avec la cigarette la
cigarette elle est pratiquement
stigmatiser ce nouveau produit il est à
stigmatiser les parts encore sting alors
chers grecs vous êtes le cerro log
discret cette semaine à l'émission c'est
le premier jeu de la grosse boule ya des
aspects plus également bucs bucolique
mais ludique ludique voilà ces émissions
et 19h nous on essaie d'informer en
séduisant et en informant bain partant
le divertissement voici ses premiers
tours de la grosse boule sans vous la
perte par émission les le premier jeu
vous risquez de perdre 20 boules voit si
on affiche pour tout le monde la
première question aujourd'hui on parle
de vin potage aujourd'hui il va potes
vous ne nous va pas ton vous vapoter jeu
non nous ne votons pas jouer mais il va
pote va potes on a pu dire autre chose
c'est un bouc qui a été choisi en 2008
apparemment c'est lors d'un sondage en
ligne sur un site français
on a demandé aux gens c'est quoi votre
terme préféré où l'on a suggéré
quelques-uns et vapoter a eu 22 9%
vingt huit pour cent de la faveur mais
quel autre terme a failli être adoptée à
la place de vapoter est ce que c'est à
ce mauvais c'est les français juste mot
gay soit
sa finale et finale au final le le
sondage a été fait en france
enfin si c'était au québec j'aurai pris
ma finale finale ça peut aller va se
moquer mais tu l'a proposé donc là c'est
moi qui n'ai pas posé vous passez à
tulle a à g de la mit l'accent de lâcher
un peu pointe et de l'anglais en fumée
tout le monde cette enfance bien vous
pensez et puis vous c'est quoi
on va y avoir la bonne réponse on
affiche la main de repenser ses flux
vais arriver ils affluent veine avons
voulu v et 5% semaines avait 7 ans
propriété dans les trains
je ne sais pas où vous avez quand même
perdu les boules atomisé fado alors on
va aller vers notre spécialiste premier
spécialiste aujourd'hui il s'agit du
docteur morissette mathieu morissette
l'institut universitaire de cardiologie
pneumologie de québec
bonjour docteur bonjour alors écouté
très sérieusement
moi je ne sais plus où on en est
maintenant quelle est la situation aux
états unis ou au canada par rapport au
nombre de cas c'est une histoire qui a
commencé à faire des bonds dans les
journaux au mois de septembre
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui deux
mois et plus plus tard
présentement la situation c'est que on
sait pas grand chose de ce sport on sait
que des gens qui tombent malades
on sait que c'est des gens qui papote et
quand j'ai des gens qui tombent malades
se résume en un nombre faible par
rapport au nombre de bateaux donc ils
raison s'inquiéter mais il faut penser
que tous les amateurs
présentement le fonctionnement donc
c'est vraiment une faible partie mais
n'en est pas moins que c'est d'une
nouvelle cause pour des maladies
pulmonaires aigus et honnêtement d'un
point de vue le scientifique ou
cliniques
beaucoup de gens pensaient qu'il y
aurait des parlements des les
conséquences pulmonaire vapoter mais de
là à dire qu'il y aurait des des effets
si luxueux et même mortelles non je
pense que la communauté scientifique et
médicale et et son docteur morissette
moi j'ai vapoter lorsque j'essaie
d'arrêter de fumer c'était en 2010 donc
depuis au moins 2008 on va pas commencer
à dire que c'est maintenant qu'on
constate que des cas de deux maladies
pulmonaires apparemment il n'était plus
qu'une liés ou va potage elle permet
chaque année de plus en plus de gens qui
va pas
donc oui on va porter plus de
probabilités qu'il ya des gens qui
développent des maladies si on veut
causer par l'abattage
donc c'est la première chose et il faut
dire aussi que c'est pas tout le monde
qui va 8 ou 10 a donc naturellement les
effets qu'on voit si des effets du donc
c'est surtout l'effet que il ya
davantage de jacques qui va pas qui
menace et alice oui professeur c'est
morissette
je veux savoir où est-ce qu'on a mené
par rapport à la recherche parce qu'on
sait que pour pouvoir généraliser les
résultats d'une recherche à une
population donnée
il faut qu'on ait testé un bon nombre de
personnes ayant fumer la cigarette
électronique ayant présenté des
symptômes qui s'apparentent à ceux qu'on
a constatée au cours des derniers mois
parce qu'on a mené avec la recherche par
rapport à cette maladie là cette
problématique que apple à rechercher les
moyens davantage de nature
épidémiologique
c'est à dire que ce qu'on fait c'est
constater les cas qui se présentent et
documenter la nature de la présentation
de ces maladies c'est davantage encore
on constate les faits d'accord d'un
point de vue plus fondamental si on veut
on essaie de comprendre comme un père de
mon laboratoire entre autres on essaie
de comprendre quelles pourraient être
les effets pulmonaire des différences
disant grézian spécifique au capotage
dont on sait qu'il ya énormément
d'ingrédients qui peuvent être apportées
de façon légale et illégale
donc l'état des recherches présentement
est ainsi de comprendre quels
ingrédients peut être dangereux pour la
santé pulmonaire et est-ce que c'est
dangereux de façon aigüe ou est-ce que
c'est dangereux
à plus long terme de façon chronique
mais malheureusement les données chez
les humains les effets à long terme
on n'en a aucune idée parce que on n'est
pas dans le long terme on est
présentement dans le court terme
le reportage c'est nouveau comme
d'habitude la majorité des gens va pas
depuis seulement quelques années
c'est très rare le nombre de personnes
qui va pas depuis 2010
donc les électronique on va savoir avec
le temps des effets aigus mais là on
commence à en avoir un avant-goût
doctement et sept mois je voulais je
voulais savoir
vous avez dit que ce n'était pas il n'y
avait pas beaucoup de gens qui sont à
qui développe ce genre de maladie à
cause du vab otage dans ce petit groupe
qui a été détectée est-ce qu'il ya
quelque chose de qui est partagé entre
ces malades est ce que j'ai un profil
particulier à ce qu'ils sont jeunes
moins jeunes ce qui a quelque chose qui
s'en remet à bien que ce soit pas ça
fait pas longtemps plus bas potage
existe je comprends bien ça excellente
question
si on se déplace au niveau des états
unis je reviendrai au canada par la
suite aux états unis ce qu'on sait c'est
que c'est surtout davantage les plus
jeunes qui va porter des produits qui
contenait entre autres des produits
cannabis qui eux mêmes ont mené 2 sets à
deux démineurs qui est un agent
liquéfiant qu'il lui de cannabis plus
facile à travailler et à se mobiliser
dans l'ide dans les liquides de papotage
donc cette population là bas c'est
davantage les jeunes qu'il utilisait
mais lorsqu'on regarde les gens qui sont
décédés que ces maladies pulmonaires le
sait déjà qui est un peu plus vieux des
gens qui étaient inconnus donc donc
llosa si on vient au niveau du canada le
premier cas qui était rapporté c'était
un jeune homme mais la majorité des cas
qui ont été rapportés au canada c'est
des personnes dans la cinquantaine
avancée soixantaine des ex fumeurs qui
va porter des débits qui de lego donc
donc c'est vraiment différent aux états
unis
avantage des victimes illégaux
contenants d'huile de cannabis et toutes
les autres agences du terrain qui
peuvent que conduire c'est ridicule pour
pouvoir mettre cannabis de bach puis au
canada indiqué de l'ego des ex-fumeurs
des gens un peu plus vieux donc vous
voyez que la population est assez
différente selon les pays mais n'en est
pas moins que ils sont qu'avoir un
éleveur large éventail de gens qui sont
à risque de ces maladies l'eau il n'y a
pas de lien qui a été fait là parce que
ces gens là avaient des maladies
pulmonaires sous jacent il n'y a pas de
bien qui a été fait jusqu'à maintenant
le moment une autre question
oui en attendant qu'on est documenté un
nombre assez jeudi un nombre suffisant
de cas pour pouvoir formuler des
recommandations pertinentes
est ce que vous pensez qu au niveau de
l'industrie on devrait comprendre des
mesures pour éviter que les jeunes ne
tombent dans ce piège là c'est quelque
chose qui va premièrement il n'est
jamais trop tard pour bien faire
c'est certain que ce que ça vienne de
l'industrie que ça vienne de la santé
publique des agences gouvernementales
des jamais trop bien pour autant pour
bien faire le problème qui est un comble
est présentement et que le papotage est
déjà disponible à large chez les fans
oui officiellement c'est disponible pour
les les jeunes de 18 ans et plus mais
vous savez très bien comme moins que les
adolescents va pas en très grand nombre
les écoles ici dans les écoles des
régions des écoles il ya 30 40 % des
jeunes qui utilisent une batteuse
régulièrement donc bon les lois ou les
faits ont un effet relativement minime
là dessus et peut même avoir un effet
problématique savoir que les jeunes
utilisent beaucoup des liquides qui sont
faits soit la maison de façon illégale
dans la question
dr morissette je voulais juste avoir
votre avis fumer la chicha ou voir
porter est ce que c'est la même chose
une petite différence entre les deux
d'un côté c'est vraiment va porter c'est
vraiment imaginer que vous avez une
goutte d'eau qui tombent sur un rond de
votre cuisinière liquide puis le docteur
mathieu morissette merci beaucoup nous
avons apporté les plus récentes
nouvelles disponibles en ce moment sur
quelque chose qu'on ne saisit pas très
bien comme l'aimant de danger de santé
mais encore une fois vous l'avais appelé
c'est un petit nombre de gens qui sont
affectés par sa queue si on compare au
nombre d'utilisateurs évidemment ça
c'est une nouvelle encourageante
merci beaucoup docteur docteur mathieu
morissette de l'institut universitaire
de cardiologie et de pneumologie de
québec dans votre horde vers un autre
institut de grand calibre à montréal
dans un instant là je vais vous demander
de répondre à la deuxième question de la
grosse boule aujourd'hui devant vous la
terre vous avez déjà perdu 20 boules
cliquez sur 100 alors voici on a fait de
cette question toujours l'histoire de se
gratter des ménages ensemble voici la
question pourquoi la cigarette
électronique fait elle tout c'est
apparemment moi je savais pas ça ça fait
tousser certains utilisateurs rapidement
est ce que c'est ça on va regarder voir
est ce que c'est la fumée aspiré est
plus épaisse ou la cigarette parce qu'on
touche
ouais est ce que c b le volume d'air
aspiré est plus grand que lorsqu'on fume
c'est parce qu'il a fait mais plus
légère donc on espère un plus grand
volume donc où est ce que c'est ici la
nicotine hérite la gorge ne consomme
plus que si on fume sierre voyez vous
avons déjà il ya pas de nicotine dans
les cigarettes et les deux passés et
puis dès le cerveau réagit calorique
hawtin en principe lorsqu'on fait du
capotage
je pense qu'on soit liée directement de
cerveau chez pas médecin mais je pense
que c'est la star de ces jeux c'est
l'éducation
j'irai la réponse b parce qu'en principe
la cigarette électronique est censé ne
pas contenir de nicotine à dakar à sagem
son principe mais des fois il ya des
gens qui en ajoutant on peut maintenant
cannabis m c'est ce que j'ai compris mes
du faux moi j'ai déjà consommé beaucoup
de choses ce qui est légal puisque tous
les cas ce soit à la porte mais c'est la
bonne réponse aux vols affichés ensemble
je trouve sur le cerveau réagit à la
nicotine
c'est un effet de hockey si vous voulez
c'est comme si on reçoit sa petite dose
de dopamine qui est aaa et ont tous et
en touche pas mais là c'est en ce qui
concerne la cigarette électronique
illégal
ce doit être souple je suis ici à la
nicotine et y a rien d'illégal
définition d'axés ses dents je vais me
tourner vers notre service technique qui
va nous aviser si je suis le serions
prêts à laurent maintenant à montréal
c'est pourtant pas très loin serions
nous prêts pour faire le grand bond de 7
lieues va montréal le là c'est comme si
on était en avion on attend un signal la
tour de contrôle et on en était à sept
îles
on était à québec à ottawa là on espère
pouvoir faire ce sont 17 lieux vers le
centre-ville de montréal bat cette news
vous savez sur l'existant la distance de
ses tubes nous sommes au centre ville de
montréal on est au centre des lectrices
je ne pas saper le dise ou prenez pas on
n'est pas encore autorisée à se rendre
au centre-ville trois bandes de jeunes
enfin sa part voici notre expert le dr
martin juneau cardiologue ses lecteurs
la prévention à l'institut de
cardiologie de montréal docteur bonjour
et puis il ya autre chose que vous
faites dans la vie il est également
professeur titulaire de cliniques
faculté de médecine de l'université de
montréal
vous êtes un grand non plus avait je
pense la capacité en rapport à voir un
grand nom c'est celle de d'être là
lorsqu il est important de parler de
prévention et je me barre lorsque vous
voyez des gens qui ont des problèmes
pulmonaires associés aux vins potage
est-ce que c'est fréquent de voir ça de
de votre côté pneumologue
moi je dis c'est une vidéo la simple
hommes de toutes leurs symptômes de mal
évidemment ces fonds ont domaine des
clips en cardiologie et grande amélioré
à tous les niveaux et mais la réception
du signal que l'on a avec goût et un est
un peu hachuré il ya de l'écho de votre
colis d'accord est-ce que nous avons un
avis technique concernant ce que l'on
pourrait faire pour améliorer les choses
[Musique]
c'est quoi c'est de bien écouter oui ils
ont des exécuteurs ce que vous auriez
une paire d'écouteurs par hasard à
proximité quelque chose que vous
pourriez connecté à votre ordinateur
docteur avez vous une paire d'écouteurs
par hasard qui flotte comme ça ou sur
votre bureau
on a l'impression qu'ils nous attendent
dans le temps en temps ça oui je pense
qu'ils ont peut-être un autre tentative
de nos peurs devenu le surveiller le
signal c'est la connexion rien fait du
tout c'est la connexion ce cas qui est
un peu faible mais ce que l'on peut
faire c'est nous voilà nous en fait
simplement on va le faire tordre
téléphone comprendre le temps de dresser
deux organisations qui allons vous
appeler pendant que l'on continue à
conversation et c'est un studio est ce
que tu as fait c'est déjà qui va pote
moins cher que l'iphone on a des
collègues qui siradiou bah oui oui alors
tu me dis là il y en a qui vont à
l'extérieur
oui c'est à l'extérieur on pourrait me
donner des noms mais non non je vous
demande pas de le faire jeudi
hypothétiquement vous pourriez m'aider
dans mes skis et ski est particulière
avoir potassé que les autres les odeurs
sont différentes de celles des
cigarettes c'est ce que c'est toujours
celle ci japon usage la cigarette
électronique c'est que au départ c'était
cigarettes qui sont conçus pour aider
les fumeurs dans la processus de sevrage
oui sauf que à partir du moment où ça
commence à poser des problèmes on
s'interroge sur la pertinence de
continuer à les utiliser
est-ce que vous pensez que ce soit en
tout cas en 3 mois de mon expérience je
suis pas passé par pour arrêter un
cigare s'est pas passée par areva
prépare le reportage qui c'est à notre
processus donc
c'est un processus qui est passé par un
juste le fait d'être conscient que c'est
un danger ou d'être en face d'un danger
est là ça déclenche l'arrêt quinze jours
avant je n'aurais pas dû j'aurais pas du
tout imaginé que j'aurais pu arrêter
c'était il ya des gens qui sont
tellement dépendants de la cigarette
traditionnelle que arrêter ce tout en
fait tout un problème est en train
chaque cas chaque expérience est d'y
figurer
c'est vraiment moi j'ai aussi le timbre
d'abord j'ai essayé de l'abattage
ensuite j'ai eu si le thème est le thème
m'a aidé pour une couple de semaines
mais après ce faux pour avoir pris sa
décision
ici on prend pas ses décisions il ya
rien qui va vite comprendre décrochage
de comment écrasé c'est ça ouais moi
c'était simple j'ai pris et j'ai pris un
cours à l'hôpital c'était un cours de 2
comment arrêter la cigarette
mais quand je dis un coup ces quatre
séances et puis le processus déclenché
avec les patchs c'était je suis pris au
jeu
parce que pour résilier je me dire un
processus qui se fait progressivement
oui bien sûr et ça vous a appris combien
de temps pourra tenter de l'arrêter
complètement non censuré au moment où je
dise arrête là il faut se mettre
d'accord mais j'ai fait le processus
c'est que après le court on a commencé
par des patchs de 21 mg et puis on a
coupé rade à 14.7 est plein c'est bon et
ça a pris dix ans le temps que je
finisse les patchs mais pendant ce temps
là à peu près un mois des mois finir
comme ça c'est à peu près comme des
tentatives de récidive après ça je n'ai
pas eu parce que j'avais compris que
c'était comme chez les alcooliques
anonymes d'ex le premier varie déclenché
tout le mariage souquet donc
c'est la première cigarette avec le
premier verre parce que généralement les
fumeurs vont te dire c'est très très
difficile c'est compliqué d'arrêter
on a bon le faire mais deux trois
semaines plus tard oui mais quand tu
commences quand tu arrives devant les
situations où tu dois choisir entre bien
dans mon sang telle santé et continue à
se brûler balade continue on va
continuer avec notre invité nicki et au
téléphone vive les téléphones vu naître
de nouvelles technologies avec le départ
alors c'est docteur juneau merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous oui à blanc
vous entends très bien vous vous
travaillez beaucoup au niveau de la
prévention est ce que je me trompe je
vous ai déjà entendu dans des entrevues
radio canada et quelques années fait
vanter les mérites de la cigarette
électronique comme outil extrêmement
précieux si on fait le bilan de santé
les négatifs et positifs si vous étiez
en faveur de cigarette électronique est
ce que vous l'êtes vrai qu'aujourd'hui
c'est absolument jettent les cônes une
fierté connais grâce à des collègues
européens il ya plusieurs années des
français en fait qui elles ont eu avant
nous et il me disait qu'avec cet outil
leur part que comme ça qui appelait
faire c'est pour les gens qui allie
fumeurs qui n'ont pas il s'arrêter
dessus mais avec les moyens
conventionnels et pâtes légumes et ses
limites camara conventionnelle la série
tectoniques est très efficace alors j'ai
j'ai essayé parce qu'on a service de
cessation tabagique à l'hôpital parce
qu'il faut réaliser qu'un patient qui
eut des pontages aorto coronarien ou qui
a subi un infarctus ou une dilatation
coronarienne c'est vraiment critique qui
l'aurait dessus mais il diminue ses
chances de moitié d'avoir un autre
accident cardiaque alors si on est
vraiment dans l'urgence ici alors des
grilles entendu sauge et je me sens en
forme et j'ai trouvé des boutiques qui
en avait et on s'est mis à proposer à
nos patients fumeurs invétérés qui avait
échoué dans leurs tentatives et j'ai
remarqué un succès je voudrais
facilement 80 % avec la cire est
électronique les gens étaient très
impressionnés les patiences part
le juste alors il est enfin quelque
chose qui me plaît cigarettes qui donne
aussi la nicotine autant que le tabac
mais quand même s'en donne et puis pour
la majorité d'entre eux est efficace
alors suis devenu assez enthousiaste
avec ça évidemment ça des plus beaux
coups a beaucoup d'organismes de santé
public nord américain qui était
fondamentalement contre qui disait que
bon c'est encore un truc de l'iscid
d'abord on connaît ça c'est comme les
cigarettes légères à l'époque alors il
faut savoir si c'est faux c'est pas un
truc les tabasser séné d'information
chinois comme ça vit ça a été ensuite
fabriqués par toutes sortes de petites
compagnies qui avaient rien à voir avec
les insultes c'est d'abord ça a été
récupéré récemment je verrai dans les
derniers tours 4 heures pour l'industrie
du tabac avec les problèmes qu'on
connaît mais il s'était pas à la base
une manigance de l'institut tendance
aussi un petit sac
un petit rappel de l'histoire qui est
important parce que je l'entends encore
beaucoup malheureusement ça a été une
invention diabolique l'instruction
toujours est il qu'un clinique nous on a
trouvé ça extrêmement efficace alors on
s'est mis à en faire la promotion mais
évidemment on voulait aussi à l'époque
est bon aucune réglementation on the 6
si urgent que le gouvernement canadien
santé canada et mettre des règles pour
encadrer lescure électronique qu'on
puisse pas acheter n'importe quoi vendre
n'importe quoi aller sur internet et
faire et ça a été long à venir
et finalement santé canada elle le fait
mais on doit dire que même aujourd'hui
les produits ne sont pas homologués
comme un médicament c'est une
certification mais kick-ass et peser
restrictive là ils vont pas rentrer dans
les boutiques qui analyse et les
liquides ils vont s'assurer que ce qui
est vendu est pas illégal un guillemets
mais quand même si c'est mieux que
d'acheter des déposé sur le marché noir
alors l'autre chose qu on préconisait
nous c'est une émotion publicité absolue
sur le chef des chroniques comme lui
tirait en anglais leicester le cd
belle-fille dans d autres sports qui va
pote ans il faut surtout pas faire ça
c'est vraiment ça doit être
on doit en faire la promotion comme un
outil pour arrêter de fumer chez les
adultes et non pas un nouveau gadget
pour les gens alors je trouve qu'il faut
avoir un équilibre je suis encore là
aujourd'hui entre la protection des
jeunes non fumeurs qu'on veut pas qu'ils
se mettent à assumer ni à ma portée et
aider les fumeurs avec un moyen très
efficace et malheureusement je trouve
que le balancier en amérique du nord
était beaucoup trop anti ce qu'elle est
étonné qu on la démolit démonise
beaucoup ont dit également qu'il ya pas
de preuve que c'est efficace ces
fouilles deux belles études randomisées
il ya l'expérience des cliniciens qui
qui dément pas et on c'est clair que
c'est mieux si vous me demandez est-ce
que c'est absolument inoffensif non on
est mieux de respirer de l'air pur mais
enfin le thabor de combustion il est
fier est électronique je pense que
l'ensemble des données adhap montre
encore que c'est moins toxiques
pas mal moins toxiques l'affairé
tortionnaires alice en fait docteur
juneau je comprends votre enthousiasme
et votre optimisme par rapport à la
cigarette électronique
mais au regard des problèmes de sortie
encouru des problèmes de santé un
potentiel qui ont été soulevées c'est
inquiétant vous ne pensez vous pas qu'il
serait pertinent d'arrêter de fumer
d'arrêter complètement de cigarettes
électroniques en ce moment le temps que
la réglementation soit adaptée au
nouveau contexte pour un meilleur
contrôle au niveau de l'industrie et
même au niveau de la sensibilisation des
jeunes non la réponse est un prénom et
vous regardez les mois je suis seul sur
une barge que tu viennes qui produit
comme
à l'instigation de se décider cdc
américains sur les cas de maladies
pulmonaires graves auxquels vous faites
allusion
le 8 novembre mieux une vie très clair
dans tous les codes barres au coeur de
lavage broncho alvéolaire c'est les gens
qui ont été à peine maladies pulmonaires
graves incluant les décès dans tous les
cas c'est de l'acétate de vitamine e qui
l'aja en cause bon évidemment les gens
très prudent vont vous dire ouais mon ex
plus pop y ait eu des cigarettes
électroniques légal ou 6 ou d'autres
composants
mais à date c'est pour ça c'est clair
qu'il s'agit de gens qui va pa du ts et
mélanger de l'acétate de vitamine e et
je pense que le message de santé
publique devraient être ne jamais
acheter
si la tecktonik sur le marché noir dans
la rue ou sur internet ne jamais va pas
été assez parce que en général c'est
sous forme huileuses et il ne faut pas
vaporiser de l'huile six envoyés dans
les poumons mais il n'ya pas que décrit
dans le monde
à ce qu'on sache dit moi je vérifie
comme douzy sur une base quotidienne
sinon plus de corps à portée de maladies
pulmonaires graves avec une cigarette
électronique vendu légalement il ya eu
un corps en angleterre d'une réaction
allergique très très agréable mais ça
aurait pu arriver avec bien d'autres
choses mais en général sur les 20
millions de vapeur dans le monde
ce qu'on a fait l'état américain lié au
tfc avec à ces tables des vitamines et
dans une eau samir une dernière question
- dr vous la meilleure solution c'est de
fumée l'art pur ça je le comprends est
ce que pouvait revenir juste sur c'est
quoi les bienfaits pour vos malades
parce que vous êtes en cardiologie
voici quelqu'un fumer la cigarette quand
ils arrêtent ils passent ils passent au
portage donnez nous un exemple où ça
s'est amélioré juste pour comprendre
enfin deux en travers de la construction
qui était à fond deuxième infarctus du
myocarde le coeur vraiment affecter sa
femme extrêmement découragés qui est en
pleurs dans mon bureau avec lui il me
dit moi j'ai tout essayé sur le fait que
par jour c'est ce jour faire un
infarctus puis bon il va y passer alors
lui gelé convaincu tu passes à la cire
et électroniques qui après trois jours
ils m'appellent
écoutez c'est fabuleux j'ai pas touché
une cigarette en trois jours je continue
bon on le suit un nous on y suit nos
patients par téléphone deux mois après
il y avait baissé sa concentration de
nicotine et un après il va porter plus
du tout aujourd'hui va très bien jamais
recommencé à fumer ceci un coq parmi
plusieurs et le plateau l'errance à
l'effort mesuré sur tapis roulant c'est
augmenter beaucoup parce que maintenant
est beaucoup plus accessible mais même
si sur la construction et qui commençait
à avoir des difficultés respiratoires
tout s'est amélioré puisque je vous dise
un exemple vous allez me dire un très
bel exemple mais j'en ai plein comme
cela on est bien contents nous avoir
donné
l'occasion de vous exprimer sur cette
question là encore une fois docteur
juneau merci beaucoup d'être venu
aujourd'hui virtuellement bois alors
c'était le docteur martin juneau
cardiologue et directeur de la
prévention à l'institut de cardiologie
de montréal
professeur titulaire de clinique à la
faculté de médecine université de
montréal
il a aussi d'autres titres non voilée on
va vous la faire écouter la machine et
will est maintenant troisième tour de la
rose bowl combien de boue la paire vous
avez déjà perdu 50 boules donc sur saint
yves ou non à ce qu'ont bien on affiche
la question on parlait des liquides
qu'on retrouve comme ça dans les dents
légal d'accord toujours les gars tout
est légal
voici non pas tout oui c'est légal est
la question
alors c'est tout le monde attend même la
régie attendait la question laquelle de
ces liquides ne trouve-t-on pas dans les
cigarettes électroniques laquais de ses
liquides on trouve pas les cigarettes
électroniques je sais pas si le
commissaire et de ben écoute et
propylène qui colle on n'en trouve pas
est ce que c'est vrai est-ce que c'est
laid éthylène glycol et il est ça me
rappelle l'alcool c'est bon c'est bon
c'est glycérine glycol elle a bien connu
glycérol qu'est-ce qu'on ne trouve pas
un problème ça me rappelle le propane
départ de punir est propre à ces jours
ci il me semble propylène ouais y'a pas
de deux y a pas eu non pas
aucune de ces réponses à 10 c
glissez c'est parce que je suis
totalement perdue avec la réponse et si
vous êtes glycérine et ça peut exploser
oui c'est ça qu'est ce que vous savez
pour le pays et il n 5 et n d'alcool
d'accord alors voir la fiche la bonne
réponse on à la basse et rool est une
pure invention de ma part mais je
trouvais ça tellement jolie comme tarn
le but sera le point france aurait dû
être avortée de willa écoute compris
méchante question qu'est ce qui se
trouve pas dans votre cigarette
électronique comme liquide 2 c on se
gratte la tête
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont pas bien en fait
mais ce qui diminue de la glycémie il y
met la glycérine absolument dans les
séries ne fût ce que je vous ai nommé
d'ailleurs il y en a sont là glycérol
mais le produit qu'on trouve pas si
l'éthylène glycol
parce que ça on retrouve c'est ça ça va
faire du lave-glace chien sans gilmar
oui et non pour une consommation humaine
patate canine mais pas pour les jeunes
eux mêmes à nos besoins
voilà on est prêt je vais vous montrer
la vidéo numéro sept en a encore
quelques minutes à l'émission la vidéo
numéro 7 c'est celle qui vous permet de
poursuivre votre réflexion sur ce dont
on a discuté aujourd'hui est toujours un
plaisir de voir ce que les collègues ont
faits et dans ce cas ci il s'agit
beaucoup des reportages d'alice j'ai
parlé de cette recherche qui a été menée
par des chercheurs américains
ouais qui ont été les premiers à parler
des décès rudy over potage mois ensuite
il ya des journalistes français qui
étaient sur la brèche également et nous
en avons abondamment
je connais mes images il n'ya que vous
est il ya des adolescents ci qui sont
très attirées par les différentes
saveurs
ils sont proposés nous rapporter un joli
voilà et puis les mises en garde qui ont
été formulés tour à tour à l'air son
paquet canada et utiliser les
influenceurs et le par c'est une
représentation de médecins les revenus
aux voitures électriques
la semaine dernière je veux juste vous
dire que tout est plus qu on a fait le
slogan est encore valides et disponibles
sur le web suivante une parenthèse de la
semaine d'attaqués sont clés comment
ranger les autos électronique comment
les vendre et ceux qui sont négatifs qui
ne veulent pas entendre parler de ça
c'était le sujet des missions on est
prêt pour maintenant qu'on a tous fait
qu'on a tout déballer les cadeaux de
noël c'est toujours moi qui reste
l'image la semaine ah oui vous avez
deviné quelle est l'image cette semaine
sa réputation a voté en faveur de
l'autodétermination de précision
déterminant c'est parce c'est aux états
unis c'est aussi ma liste
les matchs maintenant tout le monde ça
fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas des chais
pas guy carbonneau on me demande la
régie non c'est je dirais que c'est
peut-être un lien avec l'émission de la
semaine dernière au électricité énergie
quoi véhicule mais que les prix oui vous
êtes sur la bonne piste
en quoi c'est l'image de la semaine
c'est parce que c'est maintenant ok a au
prix d'une forte de 150 actuelle donc
39000 dehors c'est ce qui va nous
attendre mais il veut que c'est surtout
sur les routes de même atteint et le gag
c'est pour ça que c'est l'image la
semaine c'est quand ils ont montré ce à
tout le monde de grandes présentations
il voulait montrer c'était une auto
vraiment durable fondent comme ford et
puis là ils ont connu un coup de marteau
sur le véhicule pas de problèmes et
ensuite ils ont décidé de lancer une
balle sur le pare-brise la lfp s'était
pas placer une balle juste pour montrer
qu'ils ont le sens de l'humour que tu
t'étais on va corriger satie grand
patron dit crise dit bravo vous êtes le
grand gagnant avait fait très belle
compétition à alice en général quand et
la démission elle a raflé tous les prix
cette fois ci il faut céder du terrain à
se donner un cachet de tout ce qu'on
apprend aux enfants dès le jeune âge
nous savons tout une amie pour on est
prêt même à donner ses enfants tellement
les généreux prenez les hommes et non
non non mais non lorsque la neige
je donnerai mon enfant pour rien non non
c'est vrai que c'est un enjeu alors là
si tout pour cette semaine
malheureusement c'est tout ce qu'on a
dans la balle et la poche du père noël
qui on vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine tout le monde on voit
[Musique]